en este vídeo te mostraré cómo colocar
la antena en spot esto requiere de
precisión así que ten cuidado cuando le
pongas el silicon lo que tenemos que
hacer es desdoblar el clip puedes ver
que el clip ya tiene lados totalmente
derechos esos deben mantenerse así
queremos que se mantengan derechos pero
desdoblamos el clip completamente
intentando que quede lo más derecho
posible ahora es importante que la parte
de los extremos también queden
totalmente derechas no los vayas a
doblar porque eso facilitará a la hora
de conectar las antenas se debe mirar
algo así una vez que lo desdobla este
todo entonces toma el robot y ponlo del
lado si hay alguien que lo pueda
sostener por ti eso sería perfecto si no
un rollo de cinta como éste funciona muy
bien ahora asegúrate de que la antena
apunte directo hacia abajo e intentar
alinearlo con el interruptor por la
parte derecha del clip en el interruptor
y ya que esté bien posicionado ponle
silicon asegúrate de cubrirlo con
silicon perfectamente de ambos lados
pero no más
ahora también cuida que el interruptor
no se pegue con el silicon porque
entonces no funcionará adecuadamente el
interruptor ahora sostén mantienen
posición mientras el silicona enfría
y una vez que haya enfriado debes hacer
exactamente lo mismo del otro lado con
el otro interruptor ahí debes pegar la
otra antena y listo tu robot tendrá
antenas una vez que tu robot ya tenga
antenas vamos a ponerlo a prueba veamos
cómo funciona por ahora no voy a
encender las luces led porque solo nos
interesa ver si el robot funciona bien
puedes ver que que se mueve bien choca
un poco y después se retira pero creo
que podemos mejorar el movimiento del
robot así que solo haremos más adelante